Koby Covington is here hey call me hello
and welcome and how are you - uh yeah
what do you think I don't mind him being
on the main car I kind of get why CM
Punk they put him in uh in my Jackson on
the main card yeah there's some that
think that that are annoyed that CM Punk
is on the main card because it was
pushing other guys a little ring her
weight yeah I guess you got to look at
it in terms of you know are you looking
at it like a business are you looking at
it like strictly who deserves to be
where based on numbers right yeah do you
think that's that what do you think what
do you think that is that a good
business mover is not one of those
things that they shouldn't have done
yeah you know CM Punk is a proven draw
you know he from Pro Wrestling he sells
pay-per-view so it's definitely gonna
boost up the pay-per-view numbers so
it's interesting though because Conor
McGregor's are proven draw - but didn't
you say he was like a coked-out
leprechaun or something like that
yeah but just because I'm saying he's a
coked-up little leprechaun doesn't mean
that he's not a draw you know he stops
you know hopefully I can get that fight
down the line my favorite part of that
by the way is how you corrected him and
you put in little you put in little
leprechaun you've kind of you seem to
like you do talk a lot of [ __ ] about
other fighters and you seem pretty
comfortable doing it like did you always
do that or is it one of those things
that it's just started to feel good once
you did it oh you know it's it's always
been something I grew up doing I've
always been confident and just you know
spoke my mind I speak what a lot of the
people want to say but they can't say so
I'm just a voice for the people how much
of it is uh just kind of selling the
fight because there is there's a
business element promoting the fight and
how much of it is I really don't like
this guy or I don't like Brazilians or
whatever yeah it's a little bit of both
you know if you do something stupid like
miss weight or just do something stupid
I'm definitely gonna call you out on it
and call a spade a spade but the other
stuff yeah it's a lot of promoting you
know if people they want to take one
side or another they want to hate me
they're gonna do anything I want to see
me lose yeah cuz you call people out for
not making weight even though you're not
gonna fight them like you've copied what
that you there is no physical
possibility that you're gonna have
you're not fighting mckenzie turned what
did what did he do for mackenzie Dern I
was a very unkind comment about she
that's where I think I was eight pounds
or something it was it was a huge almost
like she went up to another weight class
but it was it was very unkind I think
what did you pick a picture I just call
her Miss Piggy better transformer from
Miss
to her face I think yeah I think I can
see where she wouldn't have probably
been in favor of it yeah no I know
she was pretty pissed off but I'm pretty
sure she blocked me on all social media
you and you don't get any [ __ ] from the
UFC for that they don't care no they
don't care man this is the fight
business man this isn't the feelings
business we're going into steel cage
getting locked in they're trying to take
you to others brain cells so a couple
words that's not gonna hurt a UFC
fighter do you think is part of it to
clear it seem like when you watch like
Conor and he fought for Chaucer although
he was so angry at Conor he just ran in
threw a punch and got knocked out is
there a part of that to or you you want
to upset people so much that they don't
fight the way they're supposed to fight
yeah there's definitely element getting
under someone's skin before the fight in
Conor was the best of doing that he got
guys so hyped up and so mad they would
come out just throwing their game plans
out the window so there's definitely
element to that that I love and guys are
gonna really wear themselves out trying
to kill me in there what started what
started the dislike of Brazil are
calling Brazilians filthy animals did
something happen that or is that just
one of those things in there in the Kobe
did he is that a direct quote yeah yeah
it's a pretty direct quote it was a yeah
but you said it in Brazil your filthy
animals your you suck I mean you didn't
say it from here you said it right there
yeah just do it
the way three people man all the
fighters that have went in there in the
past I've taken note of this throughout
my career and they call it people you
are you will die when you walk the
doctor on you buy more and when I was
walking down octagon they were throwing
stuff at me like trying to grab my
American flag and I'm all about our
system and landed the free home of the
brave so you mess with the the American
flag that I'm really gonna have some
words for you so you know they want to
give me banter saying I'm gonna die you
know I'm gonna give them some banter -
do you really dislike Brazil oh no I
love Brazilian women man yeah a couple
of times to mute it was probably a
different more expensive venture for me
than it is for you yeah yeah but it was
fun
you had to buy more than drinks for
girls okay now do the Brazilian women
though when you're trying to like talk
to him are they ever like well you know
you called the people in our country
filthy animals like is that something
that you have to get past or do they not
care no they don't care they know they
know I'm the king of Brazil man that's
all the women are romanticizing about me
and all the people are putting their
first Born's that named after their name
even a lot of people after you in brazil
yeah man they're naming their first boys
out to me
chaos king of Brazil wow I know I didn't
know did you want to fight there too
because you're fighting a dos Anjos in
Chicago it's the co-main event you all
Romero and Robert Whittaker is the main
if it's an amazing card the Chicago card
is [ __ ] phenomenal did you want to
fight in on the real card originally
yeah I was begging to fire you I really
wanted to go back to Rio that they
deserve so I paid to go back there but
you know the powers that be made they
didn't want this glorious moment to
happen on Brazilian soil that wanted it
to happen on US soil so you know I'm
fine with having paddle fights and
champagne on US soil I'm sorry were they
worried about what might happen if you
went down there I mean there's only so
much you can cover somebody in an event
with you know fifteen thousand people uh
you know I think they might have been
worried but you know I don't know I
think the security guards were more
worried about what was gonna happen to
them having boiled flies in me but I'm
not so I'm not afraid of anything I'm
not afraid of death I'm not scared that
bullets coming my way so it didn't
matter to me what do you do when you're
in Brazil like what do you do socially
like because I wouldn't imagine you
could leave the hotel because especially
the men in Brazil if you're calling them
pieces of garbage and then having sex
with their women and then they're also
naming their children after you I'd be
so pissed if I was a guy in Brazil and I
probably want to hurt you
yeah there's a lot of them you know you
know I mean fight week you don't really
do much anyways you stay in the hotel
you do media you cut way so there's not
much stuff you do I'm in Brazil but you
know in South Florida there's a lot of
Brazilians on the beaches and and I
could definitely see the anger in their
eyes but they know those filthy animals
can't touch me and what happened when
when a ver doom approached you I think
that was in Australia right where he I
mean you know for be CEO is a very big
guy what was going through your mind
when he's coming up to you and it was
legit and he was angry well he caught me
off guard I was getting ready to go
promote his show I was gonna go to Fox
Sports Australian I'm sitting down
looking at my phone you know typing some
shits tyron woodley and then all of a
sudden out of the corner of my eye I
just get like hit in the side of the
face on look back I'm like what's going
on it for bricio where dooms walking at
me with this coach Rafael Cordeiro I'm
like what are you doing man like you're
a heavy way you got to fight this
why you mess with me Oh you call my you
call Brazil Adan Paul you said filthy
animals I'm gonna kill you and then he
pulls out like a boomerang and throws
the boomerang at me and I'm just like
dude you just proven everything I said
right that you are a filthy animal that
you're gonna condone yourself like this
we're professional fighters you get paid
to fight in a cage you don't get paid to
find the streets so stop acting like a
criminal
these are a part of it though we're like
okay like like when cyborgs slide forget
who's cyborgs slap to the face is there
a thing like when you're when you're
saying stuff to a guy who's out of your
way class like you know you're not gonna
fight him so how what is he supposed to
like how is he supposed to handle that I
never said anything about Fabrice over
no no but you know understand like like
with Auslan come on yeah you know any
guys that I'm saying about or girls you
know if they're saying some about it you
know I got 24-hour security on me now so
Dan Lambert my managers got all the
money in the world so you know it is
what it is they're gonna have their
feelings hurt you know this isn't the
feelings business you know and I'm not
here to make friends I'm here to make
money when you were backstage and you
what started it with you and we spun uh
you know no comment have anything to say
about that scrub you know where you just
call them a scrub so that is one okay
you didn't say one thing about him I
mean he's not on my love under bigger
and better things you know I got a
paycheck with extra zeroes at there and
I got bigger things to focus on bigger
fish to fry
are you surprised when a guy like that
confronts you backstage like this isn't
a show where that's true life yeah yeah
it was completely fake you know you told
this friend hey man turn on the camera
real quick let's get some footage of you
talking [ __ ] Kolby Covington and he's
talking to me when he knows that the
biggest thing just happened the night
for with Conor McGregor's so all that
bus trolley stuff so UFC is already on
high alert they're like okay Kobe
nothing can happen like don't let
anything happen so he knows it nothing's
gonna happen backstage like we're
professional fighters so he knows he's
got the green light just kind of like
you know promote himself and get his
name out there and good for the little
kid you know he's a maniac in bedsheets
that night
so you weren't it wasn't it wasn't like
you were uncomfortable with what he was
saying or afraid you just were like you
didn't want to be involved
yeah just laughing I might dude yeah
okay you're here to promote your fight
and you're over here trying to yell at
me and scream and talk about me I don't
give a [ __ ] about you kid like I got
bigger things to do Junior there is a
there is something to with it raises
your profile because in the last year
I mean since since that happened in
Brazil I mean I'll you know you're
fighting for an interim belt now like
not that you don't deserve even you
thirteen and one but still your your
name is a lot more people know your name
now than they did a year ago
yeah I'm right now I'm the hottest name
in the game you can't deny that I'm in
the headlines every week you know I'm uh
I'm a I'm a money printing machine and I
mean historically in UFC the people who
talk [ __ ] they end up getting I mean
they're all good fighters but they end
up getting better fights they end up
making more money like that is kind of
what happens because it gives people a
reason to care about this fight like
this isn't just like okay I care because
it's two great athletes competing it's
like no no no there's a real personal
rivalry happening here
now do you are there things that people
can say about you that would make you
because you're saying we're professional
fighters you shouldn't be doing stuff
like that but you take a lot of shots
are there things that if people were
taking shots at you the way you take
shots that you wouldn't be as
professional no say whatever you want to
say like I don't block anybody on social
media you want to come over you want to
say you want me to die you want Isis to
come get my family I get those messages
every day so you know say whatever you
want nothing's gonna hurt my feelings
I'm not a snowflake
it doesn't hurt you when somebody says I
want Isis to come and kill your family
no I just kind of laugh at it they get
so emotional you know that they're there
and their feelings like a little girl
you're strong man yeah I thought my
bother me it would bother you oh yeah
yeah they mocked my appearance how about
when you said Mike Perry you you you
badmouth my Perry's girlfriend was that
just one of those things in the moment
like that you're like where do you stand
by that were you like one of those
things were you like I kind of shouldn't
have said that no I completely stand by
that I should have heard some of the
stuff he was saying it was fine Oh
Kobe's gonna suck my dick all Colby's
gonna do this you know he's talking
about [ __ ] we fought on the same card
when I fought in Sacramento so you know
his girlfriend was chattering - and and
she shadows the fighters - all my
boyfriend's gonna knock you out so he's
not exempt you know like she's not you
don't get a free pass remember ed murrow
Edmond Harvard and she used to get so
much [ __ ] in Rhonda's corner and he got
all the [ __ ] so so where's equal ism
like you want to be treated fairly like
a man you know and treated about like a
person you know she's not safe okay so
you saying cuz she was kind of a part of
that world and okay so the question
everybody's mind besides your fight in
Chicago are you gonna when you're in
Chicago are you gonna slap Joe Rogan's
Joe Rogan has asked you not to I saw it
on his podcast you said that you might
there was a chance that you would go to
over to the commentary table and smack
him because Joe Rogan make comments
about comments that you made about Jon
Jones kind of telling you you should
maybe relaxed because Jon Jones is a bad
[ __ ] and you responded with
maybe Joe Rogan should relax I'll smack
him when I see him in Chicago are you
gonna smack him oh you know I can't give
away my secrets you know I'm definitely
gonna have to talk to him face to face
and when I see him face to face in
Chicago I don't know what's gonna happen
tempers might fly you know I might do
something crazy
you just have to tune in so this is what
this is what I can't wrap my head around
that I feel like these fights you would
have to be so focused on the fight to do
them successfully but I feel like you
just have to just fire so many shots at
all times that every time you walk in a
room there's like a hundred and fifty
rivalries happening all at once how can
you possibly concentrate on a big fight
while also knowing oh I'm also maybe
I'll smack the commentator when I'm done
and oh yeah that guy over there I know
there's a Brazilian guy in the audience
that's right I call it a filthy animal
yeah I know yes some of the heavyweights
are yeah there's a [ __ ] and there's a
middle way throwing a [ __ ] did you
redo at me like how do you possibly
concentrate ah you know that I'm just
very calm under pressure and you know my
movement that I got going on the nerd
bash moved me no nerds safe so nobody's
saying and I don't let things get to my
mind you know a lot of people they have
so many things going on in my mind I
just just part of it too like with all
these distractions and all this stuff
but that's Rogan or if you know chid
bhaijaan
does part of that kind of keep you from
having to be obsessed with the fight
like sometimes when your mind is focused
on ten different things you don't have
to focus and worry about the one thing
does it kind of just kind of keep you a
little bit more even yeah absolutely you
know guys sometimes get so focused on
fight it's all I need to do this I need
to train extra you know I need to do
this I don't like to be that way I like
to not think about it you know I know
how to fight
I know I'm the best fighter in the world
so it's more just you know going through
the motions and I know when I get out
there you know I'm gonna turn on that
switch but in the meantime you know I
just like to stay cool and calm and
that's how I stay calm
tell me about the nerd bash movement
because I thought we were kind of living
in a society where we were empowering
geek culture and you know Comic Cons are
these huge pop culture events and and
you know video gamers make millions of
dollars and all this stuff like I
thought I thought geek and nerd culture
was kind of a powerful thing now and but
what is the nerd Bosch movement well
let's let's first establish who the
Nerds are okay the nudes the nerds are
all these cheeto Eaton dorks that are in
their mom's basement and they want to
play for at night in UFC Matchmaker and
telling me how to do my job they haven't
done [ __ ] with their lives but they want
to come on social media and act like
they can tell me what to do and all I
gotta say is next nerd on the guest list
is Ralphie dos nachos a slight
mispronunciation yeah a little bit yeah
and they're fighting the the co-main
event and I've been may events a great
fight - are you well against Robert
occur they're fought once before and I
guess there was an injury and now you
always back fighting for the
championship but I'm surprised they
moved
what's over him down onto the prelims I
kind of wanted to see him on the main
card yeah I agree you know he's a legend
in the game you know it kind of did him
dirty I don't know why they put Holly
Holm up there you know she doesn't sell
she's not gonna talk to sell the fight
so it doesn't really make sense to put
her up there what did you think about
wonder boy till I thought wonder why won
that fight I thought wonder boy won it
looked like a game of pattycake bill you
know that's not what the UFC pays for
you know I mean it looks like they're
trying to mimic like tyron woodley he's
made this the whole division boring and
that's why I'm here to save this
division and make this division great
again cuz these guys are out there
they're just throwing the least amount
of significant strikes I mean look at
them in their fight they're throwing the
most amount of significant glove touches
and the most significant hugs ever in a
fight that's just a joke sad
yeah woodenly got a lot of [ __ ] because
it was Demian Maia fight but I kind of
like you know I guess what are you
supposed to do every time you throw a
punch mine's gonna try to take you down
you handled him a lot differently yeah
and a little completely different I left
them in a pool of blood in three rounds
I doubled the significance truck strike
total in three
versus his five rounds so there's a way
you can fight him that's just excuses if
you say you need to fight him because
he's a specialist you're a wrestler you
should just stuff the steak downs in and
pound him out do you feel like are you a
sportsman after your fights do you think
like after this fight should you win
you'll approach your opponent handshake
hug you know good battle it's over uh
you know I'm definitely a sportsman but
you know I don't know about a hug you
know we might be my bag hey man
acknowledge hey good job man
good fight but you know we're warriors
were putting all on the line so but I
mean I'm not gonna be hugging like every
round trying to hug every five seconds
you know good job man you're here for
business I'm here for business
now what if what if you go in and be
like hey man that was a great fight and
he's like [ __ ] you you still call me
does not show it's like I'm not happy
with you yeah that's what I'm expecting
you know is these guys not there's not
gonna be any sportsman about it they're
gonna be salty after I knock them out
and they're not gonna want a handshake
or hug
well the waiter ah Chael Sonnen and
Anderson Silva if those guys get hug at
the end of it I mean anybody can get
along at the end of a fight that's true
is that would you look at what Chael
Sonnen did with Anderson Silva as kind
of like a blueprint for how somebody can
successfully cuz I mean channel son and
took promoting to a different level I
think in UFC ya chose one of my boys you
know we grew up in Oregon together I
used to train with him so you know I've
definitely gotten some pointers and tips
from the American uh organ gangster he
really chilled to get under people's
skin like almost nobody in history but
but did me [ __ ] up with the flag like
did something to Brazilian flag of the
actual URI sorry like yeah I think he
stepped on the flag or something like he
went one step too far and it's in the
spirit of promoting but then he had to
go like oh I shouldn't though is there
anything you've done that you're like
that was well I was one step too far no
no I know where the line is I don't ever
cross the line I step right up to it I
put my toes right on the line but I
don't what is your life what is your
personal line
ah you know there's not really a line
for me you know I do whatever I want say
what I want I know there's some some
barriers you just don't cross you don't
talk about religion you don't talk about
race and you know those are lines I'll
never cross but I mean he'll talk about
nationality yeah you really do if you
have it right okay that looks like a
filthy animal
you're screaming at people throwing
stuff at people acting like that then
don't expect for me not to say something
back to you if you're saying stuff like
that to me right yeah but I guess it
would probably make less people have
said if you said the people in this
audience are filthy animals versus the
people of Brazil are filthy animals see
that's the thing though you're not a
filthy animal unless you're accepting
that you're a filthy animal so it's it's
all about how you take it
I see so it's not just because you say
it doesn't mean it it doesn't make it so
and if you're not a filthy animal you
should know you're not affiliate but in
your experience the people that are like
how dare you say that about me have
conducted themselves like as you said
filthy animals yeah okay how do you
Brazilian teammates or people you train
with how do they respond to it like do
have you had to talk to them and go look
you know this is just what it is I'm not
promoting a fight or has there been like
any problems behind the scenes with
people that you normally would have
gotten along with yeah you know the guys
in the gym they really took it personal
you know I kind of got cut off from the
Brazilians and American Top Team in the
gym and they don't train with me tell
them hey guys I mean you not filthy
animals just because I said you know we
can still train together yeah my manager
actually had to sit down with him he
owns American Top Team Dan Lambert and
he had to sit down a man Colby's just
trying to sell fights he's trying to
make money he's trying to get a title
fight so he sat him down and gave him
the the the q and A's but you know at
the end of the day they take stuff
personal and they really take pride
buying their country yes it was her
moment where they were they were like
we're just not forgiving this guy or did
you not want to dial back or do they
want an apology that you wouldn't give
yeah that wasn't a give I said hey man
I'm promoting my fights you know if you
got a problem with that then you know
where the door is
you didn't care and how about Jon Jones
yeah I would now do how did you know Jon
coming up me and Jon lived together two
years in Iowa Central and Community
College together so you were when you
say live together you don't mean in the
same in the same dorm or in the same
dorm in the same bedroom we shared the
same room okay so you you were rumors
okay um cuz sometimes people like yeah I
know I'm from school and they just went
to school together and did you guys get
along then yeah we were like best
friends when you first met each other
what happened yeah oh you know he just
started doing steroids and he's just
freaking always had roid rage she come
home and yell at me oh [ __ ] are you
doing Colby do the dishes and he was
just like literally freaked out like I
was
this road rage in his eyes and I would
just be like dude what's your deal man
because he was trying to go from what he
was wrestling at 197 he was a national
champion junior college and he was
trying to beef up and go to heavyweight
so he thought he had to do a cycle of
roids and you know he just I just lost a
lot of respect for him he started
partying a lot doing ecstasy doing all
these drugs and and you know the rest
was history so he's been doing steroids
for a long time yeah he's been doing
them since college Wow
how does he think that about Joey yeah
how does he get as far as he did like in
the UFC for example because he had a
good run you you thought it wasn't
always testing though that's you saw him
come around so like I think two years
ago or so I see so they're kind of
recent with the sport before you know do
you everybody kind of know like did
everybody like you knew obviously the
whole time he's in UFC that guys using
steroids do people in the UFC do
fighters no okay we all know what the
deal is Jones or does it not really come
out until it's a story I think a lot of
people knew you know he was he was
wrecking Bentley's that the UFC gave him
he was you know who who curse in the
back of his car partying cocaine binges
all night and then he was fighting the
next day five rounders is make no
mistakes about it there's just not
possible to do that at that high level
without you know putting some chemical
performance-enhancing drugs in your body
and we can of course only take your word
you know for sure for sure but your
roommate this last time in the Colombian
a fight they didn't they say it wouldn't
have made sense for him to do this like
that it must have been an accidental
because it wouldn't have made he would
have absolutely no and they were gonna
test him so why would he have done I
don't know what he got popped with this
last time I feel is it turn the ball is
it called especially after he did is his
whole apology tour
yeah of like you know I've changed my
life around he dressed differently
everything was differently had him in
here talking he's a whole different
person and then two weeks later he got
popped again yeah of course man anything
he says the media or interviews you know
it's just it's a front you know he's one
of the fakest dudes I've ever met he
says he's all about God you know and
he's all about this if you're all about
God why do you have to cheating on your
wife why you doing almost your stupid
things you know like you're not a fan
you're not a guy of God so stop
pretending to be you know just embrace
your villain role embrace the bad guy
person that you are you know he'd brag
get you a lot more money did you have
him falling out with him like that was
like okay [ __ ] you and then [ __ ] you or
they just kind of over time be like yeah
I'm gonna [ __ ] on him too like
like him anymore yeah we had a pretty
big falling out when I left junior
college he just he lost the school one
day and I just wasn't cool with I was
like dude you don't treat me like that
you don't treat anybody like that
especially a friend you know that my mom
used to come and cook you meals she'd
fly you out to org and like she would do
like favors for him and like you know my
family took him in like a family member
of his own and the way he treated me is
he's not cool but you know you he was
partying a lot so you know he just he
just wasn't the same person you know
dude he's gonna come back uh I don't
know man he would he got a second you
saw a steroid violation you know he's
gonna be out a couple years they're
making excuses saying trying to get him
back you know he might come back who
knows I don't know but that's why I'm
here to say this this the UFC in and
replace him and all the other big
fighters who else you who you really
close to I'm really close to mine my
best friend is a [ __ ] a hospital one of
my best friends man we we went through a
lot together we train every day together
man we grind we grind brothers did he
how did he feel about what's been going
on did he not hear yeah about what yeah
I guess I guess excessive that's a big
question about which one specifically
yeah it's actually it was kind of funny
because he's managed by the same guys
John Jones Malky Kyle was so you know I
know my keys in his ear you know but
trying to tell him all you shouldn't be
friends with him you know that guy's
just gonna bring you down but you know
he knows with having person I am is it
hard to get in your head because I
noticed that like when Connor fought
Nate Diaz Diaz is a hard guy to get in
his head he's not a guy that could be
psyched out by [ __ ] talking and he
doesn't really care so he seemed to fare
a lot better against McGregor because he
wasn't psyched out going in so for you
is it harder to get into your head I
mean I'm sure it's not impossible but
it's just it's difficult no it's
impossible
yeah I don't have emotions I don't have
feelings I shut those off after college
so you know that's probably why I don't
have a girlfriend I don't care for girls
you know I got a different girl in my
room each day of the weeks so you're
saying you're not different from her
boyfriend no I'm very faithful I'm an
honest guy man I'm faithful if I'm in a
relationship I'm in a relationship but
I'm single man so I'm gonna play the
field and a lot of the women are
Brazilian just I would say 75% of the
Wow Wow a lot of Colombians a lot of
Spanish you know that
waylynn right like the girls that are
thicker you know big ass is big big legs
big fat booties and every day every day
it seems like a lot of girl it is a lot
but you know I'm doing a five-round
title title fight so I gotta have my
cardio up right
do you practice safe sex of course
that's the first thing you've said that
I have eject oh yeah first thing that
offended me so far was condemnation yeah
Jim did you take that for granted that
that was being practiced no I just hope
no come on
we find our own ways you know you do it
in occasion I do it every time a test
comes so yeah how long before a fight
will you not have sex just fighters have
different things about that some guys
will [ __ ] the night before and some guys
are like for three months they won't
they won't do it yeah so you'll have sex
with a stranger the day before a fight
yeah okay that's part of your your
conditioning yeah okay I gotta get that
extra testosterone pom get my you know
get my cardio work work we lose off
there's last couple pounds before
weigh-ins yeah helps me out so you don't
regret any of this obviously you're very
comfortable in the kind of the role you
have and what's been no yeah well helped
in how you're perceived how can you
regret if you don't have any emotions
what shut your emotions off like because
you say it seems like there was some
kind of a switch so what shut them off I
think just wrestling not getting what I
dreamed of in one in my whole life I
wanted to be an NCAA wrestling champ
Division one I just I felt sure you know
I got fifth it was unacceptable I should
I should have worn it that year and I
don't know I just I had so much feelings
and I let it get to me so much I was so
motion about and I was just like I'm not
gonna be like this anymore especially
coming into this business this is not a
business you want to have feelings this
isn't a feelings business so you decided
that because you got ya it's crushing if
you want to win something and you don't
want it so you got a crushed mentally
because you didn't win this tournament
then you're like no more I'm just gonna
care what what people think I mean
everybody has a worthless opinion and
they want to stay it is so you know I'm
not trying to make anybody happy was it
after was it after you lost was it were
people saying [ __ ]
you didn't like yeah there's there's
always haters along the way you know in
college high school there's always
people that have opinion on the Internet
you know so you know I just was sick of
hearing those opinions you know opinions
don't matter and they're not gonna make
a difference then when the opinions
aren't gonna help Ralphie those nachos
on June 9th when they're I don't think
that's his name
no but it's a he knows who he means okay
ah so when are you going to Chicago I'm
leaving to Chicago tonight and what you
do when you get there like you go out at
all like you don't seem like you're just
gonna you have to hole up in the room I
guess the night before you I'm guess
you're doing a weight cut now yeah I
don't really cut much weight man I just
I find in my natural way most of guys
you know that are cutting lots away you
know they I think they get an advantage
I don't need a new management I just
fight in my natural way and it would be
tough to if you're cutting weight to
have a one-night stand like right at the
indie cuz your honor the energy right
exactly and you have to keep your energy
up yeah for your your boy your virility
yeah I'm all about putting in giving the
girl you know equal treatment you know I
gotta take care of her so I gotta put in
a good hour you know an hour yeah man oh
yeah good for seven minutes and that's
it yeah that includes the drive home and
okay so you find it your own word that's
actually so I always wonder why guys
will cut like 13 pounds or 15 pounds
it's like there's no way that the the
putting that on with fluid
we're food in 24 hours can make you that
much better than somebody who's fighting
for natural we're just specially since
Kobe releases 15 pounds of fluid before
a fight yeah it doesn't make sense to me
it's not healthy it's not healthy a
these guys are drained a lot of water
from their brain and that's why a lot of
them are getting knocked out a lot
easier you know I I've never understood
it I find in my natural weight I'm not
I'm not afraid to fight bigger guys you
know I know what's gonna happen to him
yeah they sent a lot of people since
they're doing this our earlier weight
the earlier weigh-ins now there's a
whole lot more people of miss weight for
some reason because I guess they have
less time to cut out less time to cut a
few hours less time to cut Wow so
they're going like the last five to 10
pounds whatever day uh we're two pounds
were two pounds whatever it is yeah but
it gives them more time to hydrate and
eat up so I think it's better for a lot
of those guys it doesn't matter for me
I'll weigh in an hour before that's what
I'm used to doing in wrestling season
his way in an hour before and then
wrestling so that's why I've always not
cut weight because it doesn't make
as for me I mean wouldn't it be honest
er or more honest for this honesty
wouldn't be more honest for the sport if
the weigh-ins were way closer to the
fight well they are mean they are pretty
close the day before no but I mean like
like what wrestling is where you go in
an hour before the fight and weigh in so
it's your true weight before you're in I
guess they don't want to cancel fights
it's funny okay you can't be cancelling
fights right before too much money and
you want a guy the day of the fight to
be able to eat what he wants you know if
you wake up you don't want to have to
cut weight you know three hours before
you corner because I think I should get
really hurt doing that yeah but it would
also force guys they have to fight it
their natural weight right and be
cutting so much weight you know guys
like kabhi would have to fight 170 you
know guys you know that are big for the
weight class would have to go up away
class had force them to fight the
natural way maybe that's the steps I
need to do that and make this safer yeah
before we before we wrap up or you know
you if you talk you've talked about
going up or going down and wait I mean
obviously this fight you're fighting
you're not going to worry about the next
one but we're who would you want at
lightweight if you had to take somebody
or who would you want at middleweight
you know I'm definitely looking at that
could be been Connor both those guys
piqued my interest I think those guys
you know Connors fought and won seven
against ideas so he's he's proven he
wants to go up a way I can meet them and
catch weight so I you know I could
probably make 55 and then obviously I
want to go after the number-one guy 85
Whitaker you know I think he's a pretty
good matchup for me he got knocked out
by a choirboy
wonderboy so you know if he's getting
melted by him I'm sure I can Melton so
we're on we're not on great terms with
John Jones maybe we're gonna slap Joe
Rogan not on great terms specifically
with the men of Brazil tomorrow who some
are not going not good with with the
with who's my because he said he wasn't
gonna say anything but then but you ever
do miss not not great right now
and also you you added the word nachos
to the name of your opponent for this
Saturday so what I'm trying to say is
people should probably tune in to the
pay-per-view UFC 225 in Chicago this
Saturday because it's gonna be a show
it's gonna be a show it's gonna be a
spectacle you know that's what
everybody's paying top dollar for me
know I'm the bad guy
I'm a super villain but this is real
life super villains and bad guys win in
real life we'll see if the nerd bash
movement continue